ja herzlich willkommen zurück aus der
sommerpause aus einem wie sie sehen
neuen studio und mir gegenüber sitzt
einer der einflussreichsten soziologen
unserer zeit andreas ragwitz trifft mit
seinen gesellschaftsanalysen immer
wieder den nerv der zeit vom populismus
über die zunehmende spaltung der
gesellschaft bis hin zu den
schattenseiten der selbstoptimierung
seine bücher die gesellschaft der
singularitäten und das ende der illusion
die stehen heute nicht nur hier bei uns
auf dem tisch sondern auch in den
bücherregalen zahlreiche politikerinnen
und entscheidungsträger ist eine stimme
hat also gewicht herzlich willkommen
herr ragwitz ja wie fühlt sich denn das
an wenn man weiß dass menschen die an
den hebeln der macht sitzen die eigenen
bücher lesen
naja das betrifft ja eigentlich mein
selbstverständnis als soziologe ganz
generell und der halte ich ein bisschen
mit dem was der philosoph odo marquard
mal gesagt hat nämlich dass philosophen
die bücher nur für andere philosophen
schreiben das sei ungefähr das gleiche
wie bäcker die brötchen nur für andere
bäcker backen
also das würde ich sagen wenn der
soziologie ist es im grunde ähnlich also
wenn meine soziologen nur bücher für
andere soziologen und ethnologen
schreiben würde das wäre mir eigentlich
zu wenig verwegen schreiben sie die
bücher also ich schreibe sie natürlich
einmal schon auch für die
fachwissenschaft aber ich schreibe sie
auch für eine größere öffentlichkeit und
das ist natürlich eine gratwanderung
weil ich kein populärer autor bin und
das eigentlich auch nicht sein möchte
aber diese gratwanderung zwischen vach
diskurs und größere öffentlichkeit das
möchte ich eigentlich versuchen also
beides zu erreichen also geht man jetzt
nicht darum politiker zu erreichen und
es geht mir darum eigentlich schon die
öffentlichkeit die interessierten
leserinnen und leser zu erreichen und
davon gibt es eine ganze menge nach
meiner erfahrung auch in den letzten
jahren also es ist nicht so dass ist
kein interesse gelte für die soziologie
ganz im gegenteil also diese selbst
aufklärung der gesellschaft die die
soziologie anvisiert das ist etwas was
denke ich gerade in den letzten jahren
auch angesichts der krisenhaften
entwicklung in den westlichen
gesellschaften also immer
mehr auch auf interesse und resonanz
stößt der hand für soziologen und
soziologen sind solche krisenzeiten ja
besonders interessant also was gerade
stattfindet die korona krise ist also
was wäre ein unfreiwilliges
sozialexperiment und dass man
wahrscheinlich auch soziologie in
gewisser weise auch dankbar
welche lehren haben sie dann bis jetzt
gezogen aus dieser krise also ich bin
erstmal natürlich nicht dankbar für die
krise das wäre das wäre fast ein
bisschen zynisch also in diese krise ist
ja nur zunächst einmal obwohl ja dann
viele gleich kommentiert haben dass man
auch dass diese krise eine chance sein
wenn die krise ist zunächst mal eine
katastrophe für viele menschen auch
weltweit die sachen nach der lehre das
finde ich gar nicht so einfach zu
beantworten also hat ja auch sehr
schnell auch finde ich ein bisschen
vorstellen diese kommentare gegeben dass
die korona krise einen epochenbruch
bedeuten würde
da wäre ich sehr vorsichtig also ich
denke nicht dass wir hier wirklich an
epochenbruch erleben sondern dass wir ja
auch bestimmte strukturmerkmale spät
moderner gesellschaft noch mal sehr viel
dramatischer also wie in einer unter
einer lupe im grunde in dieser krise
sehen darüber werden wir sicher auch
noch mal eingehen
aber ich denke auch jetzt persönlich was
mich schon
also auch betroffen hat in der krise ist
oder auch betroffen gemacht hat diese
zerbrechlichkeit das sozialen dieser
rechtlich keine gesellschaft das ist ja
etwas was soziologen soziologen ja
häufig gar nicht im mittelpunkt haben
weil wir uns geht es ja eher und soziale
ordnung unsere produktion vielleicht
auch machtverhältnisse ungleichheiten
aber doch relativ stabile verhältnisse
und jetzt haben wir auf einmal so eine
ausnahme situation in dem von einem tag
auf den nächsten also bestimmte
möglichkeiten überhaupt nicht mehr
gegolten haben man konnte teilweise die
wohnung nicht mehr verlassen geschäfte
bei einem geschlossenen schulen waren
geschlossen
die grenzen waren geschlossen also dinge
die man sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen konnte fanden auf einmal
statt und man sah dann doch wie
zerbrechlich diese soziale ordnung ist
wunderbar das ganze noch ist also wie
zerbrechlich und wie veränderbar sie ist
und auf der anderen seite aber auch und
das ist jetzt die anden die kehrseite
man ja auch gesehen wie trotz dieser
zerbrechlichkeit und auch dieser deal
herausforderung durch die ausnahme
situation doch viele dinge irgendwas in
den westlichen gesellschaften relativ
stabil weiter gelaufen sind
also man hat dann zum beispiel sich
schnell umgestellt nicht dass man hat
zum beispiel viele interaktionen und
digitale verlagert oder die menschen
haben zum großen teil sehr diszipliniert
auch auf klassische distanzen reagiert
und so weiter also insofern ist es für
mich so eine ambivalente erfahrungen mit
der korona krise einmal diese große
zerbrechlichkeit von gesellschaft die
gerade ist auch meine generation vorher
so gar nicht erlebt hat möchte 70 und
man hat eigentlich in den jahrzehnten
seit dem gesellschaft als etwas stabiles
erlebt also die kriegsgeneration hatte
natürlich ganz andere erfahrungen
gemacht oder zum beispiel auch die
person in ostdeutschland die revolution
89 mitgemacht haben
aber als westeuropäer kennt man
gesellschaft relativ stabil und dann auf
einmal ein solcher eine solche
ausnahmesituation die jetzt in der krise
das ist wirklich auch etwas was denke
ich soziologen nachdenklich macht
ich fand es interessant wie gut auch
bestimmte gesetze und regeln verboten
schnell akzeptiert wurden und umgesetzt
wurden die ziemlich radikal waren und
wenn man zum beispiel sachen klimawandel
die forderungen der kleber jugend hört
und dann sagen wir mal das ist nicht
umsetzbar das kann man nicht machen
das stimmt also ich meine was man jetzt
natürlich sieht in dieser
krisensituation ist das doch die politik
oder der staat also das politische
system
doch letztlich über große macht
potenziale verfügt das ist ja auch etwas
ich denke dass es so seit den 90er
jahren auch in der öffentlichen
diskussion eine sich ja eigentlich
wunder ein so ein topos ausgebildet hat
dass der staat sich eher zurückziehen
soll
auch stichwort die regulierung stichwort
wettbewerbs staat also ein staat der im
grunde seine eigenen möglichkeiten auch
bewusst einschränkt oder auch weil er
meint dass er vielleicht ineffizient sei
und jetzt in dieser situation ist der
staat gefragt als er muss auf einmal
reagieren und das tut er auch und jetzt
sieht man aber einmal dass der staat
natürlich auch diese möglichkeiten hat
also max weber hat ja vom staat als dem
monopol legitimer gemeinsamkeit
gesprochen das ist ja so eine formel die
wir ja alltäglich schon gar nicht mehr
uns gar nicht bewusst sind aber dass der
staat natürlich wirklich dann auch wenn
es darauf ankommt auch mit physischer
gewalt irgendwann verhindern kann dass
personen ihre wohnungen verlassen
das ist natürlich doch noch mal eine
bewusstwerdung
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen gut
dass der staat jetzt ja macht r hindert
ja im wesentlichen also eher verhindert
bestimmte dinge als er kontrolliert und
er hat kontrolliert das kann er
natürlich problemlos auch weiterhin aber
etwas schwieriger wird das natürlich
wenn es darum geht positiv bestimmte
dinge hervorzulocken in der gesellschaft
das ist ja denke ich die eigentliche
herausforderung so stößt da der staat in
grenzen wenn es zum beispiel darum geht
klimafreundliches verhalten auch zu
mobilisieren da geht es nicht nur um
verbote und wegschließen sondern eben
auch um einen positives und da sich die
situation sicher noch mal etwas anderes
was die korona krise zeigt irgendwie
auch wie unterschiedlich die einzelnen
menüs und gesellschaftsschichten sind
und die einzelnen staaten die
gesundheitssysteme die einleiten sehr
stark darunter die anderen verarbeiten
das besser aber die maske aus dem wohl
macht uns irgendwie auch alle gleich
insofern ist das ein richtiger bruch
also weil sie schreiben ja in ihrem buch
das vor drei jahren erschienen ist die
gesellschaft der singularität fulminante
zeitdiagnose und die haupt diese ist
eigentlich geht es uns heute darum bei
allen möglichst besonders zu sein
außergewöhnlich und einzigartig
schicke wärme und wie leben sie denn so
ein ausgefallenes designerstücke und
wochenend trip in die nächste punkte
dann geht es ihnen also gut
willkommen in der selbstbestimmten
spätmoderne als kurator ihres lebens
setzen sie auf einzigartigkeit ihre vita
ein kunstwerk unverwechselbar singulär
laut ragwitz sind wir im kultur
kapitalismus angelangt laden dinge mit
bedeutungen auf die über ihre reine
funktionalität hinausgehen wie ihr neues
design stück das ist für sie ja auch
mehr als ein simpler stuhl
doch aufgepasst ohne es zu merken sind
wir teil von etwas neuem geworden der
masse der einzigartigen im gegensatz zu
früher als man zur masse der möglichst
gleichen gehören wollte mit pauschal
ferien im süden und an das haus im
grünen
[Musik]
von dieser nivellierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft haben wir uns
längst verabschiedet
heute steht das designte optimierte ich
im vordergrund und geht seinen eigenen
weg
wer liegt nicht wert auf eine
individuelle erscheint witz inwiefern
legen sie selbst den wert auf eine
individuelle in erscheinung
ich meine nicht mehr sicher auch ein
produkt dieser gesellschaft der
singularitäten aber gleichzeitig als
soziologe versuche ich das immer auch
schon wieder zu beobachten also eine
gewisse distanz zu halten also sofern
man spielt mit und gleichzeitig steht
man außen vor und beobachtet oder muss
die theorie selbst irgendwie einzigartig
und singulär zahlen gibt es auch diesen
druck
naja das ist eine interessante frage
wenn man natürlich sagen kann dass diese
singular regierungs prozesse also diese
orientierung am besonderen im
einzigartigen am nicht austauschbaren ja
in ganz verschiedenen feldern der
gesellschaft zirkulieren und dass auch
die gerade die klassischen kulturellen
felder dabei eine große rolle spielt und
eben auch die wissenschaft also die
geistes und sozialwissenschaften sind
hier auch man könnte sagen würden ja
auch eine art kulturellen markt also
auch eine aufmerksamkeit und
valorisierung des marktes über darum
geht auch anerkennung innerhalb der
wissenschaft oder außerhalb der
wissenschaft
neben für bücher für aufsätze und so
weiter zu finden
und natürlich gerade die wissenschaft
setzt der klassischerweise das ist ja
das was wissenschaftler auszeichnet auch
novität auf originalität dass
wissenschaft wird ja gar nicht einfach
reproduzieren was es immer schon gab
sondern eben gerade auch das neue das
ist jetzt auf das neue und insofern
könnte man schon sagen dass auch die
wissenschaften also gerade die geister
sozialwissenschaften auch märkte könnte
man sagen so singuläre gehört guter
liefern wie eben bücher aufsätze und
theorien und so weiter und dieser diese
sehnsucht nach singularität die betrifft
ja wirklich alles also nicht nur
irgendwie meine kleider sondern danach
was ich zum frühstück isst wo ich meine
schreibe ich meine reise planen was mein
job ist und so weiter
wie sag ich dazu gekommen hier zunächst
müsste man vielleicht auch noch mal klar
machen was überhaupt mit der singular ja
gerne eine singuläre
jung genau gemeint ist das ist ja ein
relativ neuer begriff den ich dann
verwende wobei er natürlich im
zusammenhang steht auch mit einem
durchaus klassischen phänomen nämlich
das was man individualisierung oder
individualismus nennen das ist ja ein
klassischer topos auch der soziologie
dass die moderne gesellschaft eigentlich
eine individualistische ist und das
würde ich auch so unterschreiben und
aber mit der singular regierung das ist
man könnte sagen fast so eine art
individualisierung 20 das ist nochmal
eigentlich eine radikale reformen der
orientierung am einzigartigen und
besonderen und zwar was man sich da
denke ich einmal klar machen muss es
geht nicht nur um die individuen also
der begriff individualismus suggeriert
das ja dass die individuen besonders und
einzigartig sein wollen das ist
sicherlich auch so also wir haben seit
der romantik könnte man sagen also diese
diese vorstellung des individuellen ichs
das war erstmal ein nischenphänomen ist
dann aber in der spätmoderne seit den
70-er 80-er jahren würde ich sagen immer
mehr auch im mainstream der spätmoderne
kultur angekommen aber es geht nicht nur
um die individuen sondern es geht eben
zum beispiel auch um die dinge sie
hatten ja selber auch einige beispiele
genannt also dinge objekte im film
beispiel war es ja auch so
diese symbolisieren die objekte werden
also dass dass das möbelstück
einzigartiges dass dieses studio dieses
neue studio in dem wir sitzen das eben
auch eine singularität anspruch hat das
zb auch nahrungsmittel bio produkte oder
die herkunft der produkte spielt auf
einmal eine rolle oder selbst etwas wie
ein telefon ist dann wenn das einer von
einer bestimmten marken wie zb apple
kommt dann erscheint es nicht
austauschbare erscheint ist teil einer
bestimmten designwelt das heißt also die
objekte welt ist mittlerweile sehr stark
man sollte sagen singulär aufgeladen das
sind eben nicht mehr nur die
industriellen massengüter obwohl das
sieht es teilweise ja immer noch sind
aber es geht darum dass der der
betrachter die beobachterinnen also in
diesen objekten mehr sieht mehr
wahrnimmt eben einzigartigkeit und damit
auch so was wie authentizität so was für
emotionale ansprache und so weiter also
sofern die objekte welt also wenn wir
uns das anschauen gerade in die
metropolregionen wie hier in zürich oder
anderswo ist also immer mehr an in den
letzten jahrzehnten auch die städte
selber singularität worden also auch die
ort da sind wir also auf eine zweite
neben die räumlichen einheiten
signalisieren sich in der spätmoderne
also diese vorstellung die industrie
stellte die alle gleich sind das war ja
noch in der forschung die industriellen
moderne und da war auch zufrieden wenn
man in der stadt lebt die so ist wie die
anderen städte wenn das eigentliche
lebensbedingungen sind
das ist auch immer mehr abgelöst worden
eben von einem städtewettbewerb also der
stellte die um singularität konkurrieren
die also auch wohl auch die bewohner von
ingolstadt eigentlich etwas
außergewöhnliches erwarten zum eben
lebensqualität überhaupt dieser maßstab
nicht nur lebensstandard sondern auch
lebensqualität das ist ja sehr viel
umfassender also man erwartet auch von
den orten im grunde nicht
austauschbarkeit könnte und sagen und
das ganz das gleiche gilt auch für
zeitliche einheiten also events zum
beispiel oder projekt das sind ja alles
auf phänomene wo es darum geht das in
einem begrenzten zeitraum große
intensität gewissermaßen produziert wird
dass es nicht darum die zahl das
zeitlich sich das gleiche immer wieder
wiederholt wie sagen wir mal einen
klassischen fabrik wo man immer die
gleichen wohl immer die gleichen
aktivitäten sich immer wiederholt haben
und es geht darum eben den besonderen
moment letztlich zu erleben was und
austauschbaren das nicht unschlagbar
auch im moment also auch diese idee
quality time besondere momente auf den
reisen beim urlaub usw
das sind alles zielvorstellungen von
singular regierung die eigentlich für
die spätmoderne kultur prägend wirken
und das gilt am ende dann sogar und da
wird es ihm wenn er noch komplizierter
für community für gemeinschaften für
kollektive und da sieht man dass man
sich auch im grunde von dieser
klassische vorstellung des
individualismus damit auch entfernt die
singular regierung noch viel komplexer
wir haben deswegen paradox das ist wenn
eine gemeinschaft irgendwie
einzigartigen haus ist aber dann ist man
teil davon ja aber aus teil dieser
gemeinschaft irgendwie ja auch einziger
die gemeinschaft zu ja ich bin mir das
eigentlich eine idee die georg simmel
also der große soziologe und 1900 schon
hatte der also gerade auf diese diese
darauf hingewiesen hat dass sie auch
gemeinschaften für sich genommen einzige
was wäre ein beispiel dafür ein beispiel
wären zum beispiel die regionalen
community ist also wenn sie zb ist diese
bewegung wie in schottland oder
katalanien neben also wo es darum geht
so eine regionale 1
stark zu machen also man hat eine
kollektive identität dieser einheit und
dann geht es eben darum dass eben die
schotten für sich genommen also
besonderheit beanspruchen eben eine
besondere geschichte zum beispiel auch
eine besondere landschaft und so weiter
also gerade diese ganzen region ist
ische bewegungen sind eigentlich ein
sehr gutes beispiel würde ich sagen auch
für einen symbolismus der kollektive und
könnte man nach so protestbewegungen wie
blackberry oder freitags für future oder
identitäts politisch gesprochen
irgendwie das schwarz sein oder trans
personen oder so sieht das auch das
müsste man im detail sich anschauen
also ich würde jetzt zum beispiel ex
mieter nicht so ohne weiteres darunter
fassen sondern ich würde sagen da ist im
grunde eine fast klassische klassische
moderne bewegung und die muss darum geht
also anerkennung also die gleiche
anerkennung wie alle anderen auch als zu
verlangen das schwarze eben gegen die
gegen die diskriminierung ankämpfen das
ist im grunde ein klassisch klassischer
standard des gleichen also der bewusst
nicht um besonderheit geht sondern
ungleichheit so scheint es mir
jedenfalls aber es gibt natürlich auch
im bereich von tnt politics teilweise
auch tendenzen
die besonderheit der einzelnen community
zum beispiel die usa hervor zu heben als
die gemeinschaft der hispanics oder
selbst derjenigen die italienischer
abstammung sind also es gab ja auch
immer untersuchen letzten jahren das war
ganz interessant dass man sieht dass
gerade in den usa dann auch in der so
genannten weißen bevölkerungsmehrheit
menschen ihre wurzeln wieder entdecken
also dass sie aus italien stammen oder
das skandinavien stammen und dann wird
im grunde dass auch diese einzelnen
dieser eigene geschichte nach mehr
rekonstruiert so dass dann so eine
kollektive identität als gruppe auch
nochmal fabriziert wird und das ist
denken und der grund dafür ist ja
offensichtlich dass diese singulären
einheiten identitätsstiftend wirken dass
man könnte ja warum dieser ganze
singular ismus was ist denn eigentlich
der reiz daran und der reiz ist offenbar
das singuläre einheiten und dass sie als
objekte sind ob das worte sind also ob
das eine zeitliche einheiten oder
kollektive sind eben identitätsstiftend
wirken und dass sie häufig auch
offizieren das heißt also emotional
ansprechen und sehr sehr viel stärker
als und da ist er jetzt beim
gegenbegriff als phänomene in der
sozialen logik des allgemeinen wird wir
haben uns die ganze zeit über dieses
als besonderen gesprochen aber man muss
natürlich auch die konkurrierende logik
sich klar machen die soziale logik dass
allgemein und das interessante ist ja
dass in der moderne
wenn ich also mit dem riff moderne also
jetzt die die westlichen gesellschaften
seit dem achtzehnten jahrhundert mal ne
also seit der industrialisierung der
demokratisierung der urbanisierung und
so weiter also das sind ja auch schon
250 jahre dass man sagen kann dass diese
moderne gesellschaft ja erst einmal im
kern sehr radikal auf eine soziale logik
des allgemeinen gesetzt hat also auf
rationalisierung auf standardisierung
auf universalisierung und das ist dann
aber von anfang an stichwort romantik so
als gegen moment könnte man sagen eine
logik des besonderen sozialen look des
besonderen oder singulären gegeben hat
das war aber könnte man sagen erst mal
im historischen verlauf er hat eben eine
gegenkultur eben auch in nischen
phänomen das ist das was durchaus
einflussreich war die hat sich aber wie
durchgesetzt so ein vor etwa 50 jahren
70 80er jahre sagen sie gab es diesen
radikalen wandel vor der moderne zu spät
moderne die jährigen jahre an rp der
romantik ist bestimmt hier in sehr genau
das ist würde ich sagen auch genau der
dieser interessante strukturwandel den
man beobachten kann also die moderne
selber hat ja auch schon eine geschichte
die hat sich auch selber entwickelt also
zunächst und der bürgerlichen moderne
des neunzehnten jahrhundert zur
industriellen moderne des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die industriellen moderne
waren natürlich man könnte sagen soziale
logik des allgemeinen und der
rationalisierung par excellence
also die industriestädte die
fabrikarbeit die nivellierte
mittelstandsgesellschaft und so weiter
also die logik des gleichen letztlich
und das ist ein seit den 70er jahren
einer in einer wirklich bemerkenswerten
war also umgekippt und ich denke das was
man ja gerne spätmoderne gesellschaft
und manche sagen auch postmoderne
gesellschaft oder hoch moderne
gesellschaft was diese eben von der
industriellen moderne und von dem was
wir ja vorher gewohnt waren moderne zu
nennen unterscheidet ist tatsächlich das
besondere die es vorher natürlich auch
schon gegeben hat aber eher in nischen
dass die eigentlich immer mehr struktur
bildet geworden ist und sie immer mehr
eigentlich ins zentrum der gesellschaft
hervor und was waren aus ihrer sicht da
die auslöser die entscheidenden und die
ursachen die ereignisse liegen die zum
kippen gebracht genau das ist jetzt
natürlich genau die frage warum eigen
um diese soziale logik des besonderen
warum ist sie so stark geworden oder das
natürlich die soziologie des allgemeinen
damit verschwunden wäre gibt es auch
weiterhin
aber die ich würde sagen dass sich dann
mehrere faktoren seit den 70er 80er
jahren eher miteinander kombiniert also
tatsächlich sind die 70er 80er jahre so
eine art gebrochen schwelle also da hat
sich wirklich etwas verändert und zwar
in verschiedenen bereichen also wir
haben einmal einen wirtschaftlichen
wandel ökonomischen wandel der letztlich
dieser den anspruch des singulären sogar
die ökonomischen transportiert ist
stichwort ende der industriegesellschaft
stichwort post industrialisierung
stichwort entstehung also eines
kognitiven und kulturellen kapital ist
das müssen sie erläutern jan beispiel
also das hatten wir ja vorhin auch schon
einige beispiele im grunde genannt also
dass man sagen kann dass die warenwelt
in der spätmoderne eben eine ist die von
der immer mehr von der die konsumenten
immer mehr erwarten dass im grunde sagen
eine differenz markiert wird dass man
das eben nicht nicht austauschbare güter
produziert werden sondern nicht
austauschbaren also dass da irgendwie
eine authentizität in den gütern
vorhanden ist also nehmen sie zum
beispiel den tourismus also die
ausbreitung des tourismus als globale
globaler wirtschaftszweig das ist ja ein
ergebnis der letzten jahrzehnte wo es
dann eben auch darum gehen muss dass man
gewissermaßen also auch die
touristischen unternehmen eine differenz
markieren dass sie also besondere orte
letztlich auch vermarkten muss man
natürlich sagen und dass auch die
urlauber erwarten von ihrem urlaub diese
besonderen momente
also insofern haben also man könnte
sagen ein konsumenten kapitalismus der
weit über das hinaus geht also was man
klassischerweise industriekapitalismus
genannt hat also industriekapitalismus
könnte man sagen ging es ja bei gütern
primär darum dass sie nützlich oder
vereinfacht gesagt dass sie nützlich
sind und dass sie billig sind also
dieser stift muss schreiben können und
da darf nicht zu viel kosten und jetzt
geht es darum dass da irgendwie meine
identität nichts einfacher als das wohl
etwas verwirrt oder und man sieht
natürlich auch dass das ganze da steckt
auch ein ökonomisches interesse darin
derweil man könnte sagen also auch der
markt für diese standard güter für die
industrie einen standard güte auch
irgendwie
erschöpft war also irgendwann 50er 60er
jahren hatte man ja auch eine breite
massen wohlstand der sich etabliert sind
in den westlichen ländern
und danach ist natürlich für die
ökonomie auch die frage wie geht es
jetzt weiter also wo gibt es eigentlich
jetzt noch wachstumsmöglichkeiten
da gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
auch über globalisierung natürlich über
automatisierung aber vor allen dingen
natürlich auch eben über diese
profilierung konnte man sagen neuer
gewitter in denen dann auch sehr viel
wissensarbeit auch forschung und
entwicklung drin steckt auch natürlich
design und marketing drin steckt aber
diese frage aber diese industrielle
produktion ist dann eigentlich gar nicht
mehr das zentrale sondern wir haben die
eben hier eine ökonomie die die also man
könnte sagen immer mehr zu einem
kulturellen kapitalismus geworden ist
das ist also ein ein strang also ein
segment könnte man sagen der
entscheidend ist also für die entstehung
der gesellschaft singularitäten dann
haben wir aber ein zweites element und
das ist mindestens ebenso wichtig und
das verzahnt sich dann auch mit dem
ersten und das ist ein kulturelles
moment das ist eben also 68 ist ja nur
eine chiffre aber dahinter steckt ja
eigentlich viel mehr nämlich das was man
eine art selbstverwirklichung revolution
in der westlichen kultur in den 70er
jahren nennen könnte eine revolution
nennen sie das genau also man kann das
schon sagen das ist eine kulturelle als
eine kulturrevolution das ist ja auch in
den 70er jahren von dem
politikwissenschaftler engelhardt
eigentlich schon sehr gut damals
analysiert worden er sprach von einer
silent revolution also einer stillen
revolution also man sieht gar nicht so
genau wie sie wie abläuft aber sie ist
eigentlich so wirkmächtig das im grunde
meinte seidel leitende werte auch in der
gesellschaft sich verschoben haben
also weg von den klassischen pflicht und
akzeptanz werten in den dann auch jeder
denn so sein wollte wie der andere und
bestimmten sozialen pflichten folgen
wollte hin immer mehr zu werten der
selbstverwirklichung und der
selbstentfaltung eben dann auch der
individualität der kreativität der
emotionalen erfüllung usw
das sind ja alles werte die man aus der
romantik kennt die also auch eine lange
geschichte eigentlich wurde in der
moderne haben und dass eben auch werte
die singularität favorisieren
man erwartet daneben besonderheit
einzigartigkeit authentizität
emotionaler erfüllung und dieser dieses
werte cluster der selbstverwirklichung
ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht frei von
tieren in der gesellschaft sondern hat
schon auch eine bestimmte soziale träger
gruppe und das ist sehr eindeutig das
was man die neue mittelklasse nennen
könnt ihr die eben auch sich seit den
70-er 80-er jahren herausgebildet hat
das ist ja spannend das sagen sie also
es gibt eine spaltung dieser
mittelklasse oder mittelschicht ist sie
reden absichtlich von klasse und da gibt
es eine obere und untere mittelklasse
und diese werte der selbstverwirklichung
und so weiter diesen frauen da in dieser
oberen mittelklasse verwirklich
vielleicht können sie dir noch ein
bisschen mehr bescheidenheit wäre das
ist genau also jetzt müsste man auch
noch mal sagt also dass in der
industriellen moderne der 50er 60er 70er
jahre
da kann man viele händler nivellierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft sprechen das
ist ein begriff dass das deutschen
soziologen helmut schelsky das heißt das
war eine gesellschaft die relativ
egalitär war die auch kulturell wo die
lebensstile in der gesellschaft relativ
ähnlich waren also im mittelstand der
arbeiterschaft usw
und jetzt im grunde seit den 70er jahren
könnte man sagen aus dieser aus dieser
großen nivellierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft auch ein nach
oben hin eine gruppe heraus gebrochen
oder aufgestiegen
und das sind eben vor allen dingen die
neuen akademiker also wir erleben ja
auch genau in einem gleichen zeitraum
also ein doch eine radikale
akademisierung der westlichen
gesellschaften also so dass wir sind
vielen ländern es mittlerweile schon ein
drittel der gesellschaft als
akademikerin akademikern bestehen 50er
jahre war das ja nur fünf prozent das
war eine ganz kleine bildungseliten
mittlerweile ist das aber eine relativ
große gruppe
und diese gruppe sind übrigens sondern
auch personen die vor allen dingen im
kognitiven und kulturellen kapitalismus
arbeiten also in der wissensökonomie
arbeiten also in hochqualifizierten
berufen und die derzeitig eben auch
gerade träger des genannten werte
behandelt sind also der wertewandel in
richtung selbstverteidigungs werte wird
eigentlich vor allen dingen von den von
den hochqualifizierten für den
akademikerinnen getragen die häufig auch
in der metropolregion leben
und das ist eigentlich man könnte sagen
eine neue gruppe die man zwar weiterhin
auch mittelklasse nennen könnte weil die
einkommen eher mittel sind aber das ist
eine gruppe die eben auch über ein hohes
kulturelles kapital verfügen oder hohes
bild und kapital verfügen und die dann
natürlich auch dieses singularität
spiele über die wir sprachen auch im
konsumbereich mitspielen also die auch
die träger könnte man sagen dieser
interesse an der diesen produkten oder
an den bioprodukten und so weiter sind
natürlich die säkularisierung würde ich
schon vermuten geht auch darüber hinaus
sie betrifft nicht nur die neue
mittelklasse also wir haben sie auch in
anderen teilen der gesellschaft aber
eigentlich ist die neue mittelklasse die
sich der seit den 70 er 80 er jahren
herausgebildet hat in so einer art
primäre trägergruppe und auch der
singular jungs prozess und sehen wir das
im grunde das kulturelle das sozial
strukturelle und das ökonomische sich
hier miteinander verquickt und eben
zusammengenommen hervorbringt eine
verstärkung dieser sozialen logik der
singular ist irgendwie könnte man meinen
das sind so die gewinner hat die
gewinnerinnen dieses prozesses ist in
der spätmoderne diese obere
mittelschicht mittelklasse aber es gibt
auch schattenseiten dieser ganzen
entwicklung also wenn wir auf die
selbstverwirklichung selbstoptimierung
gehen dann sagen sie schreiben sie in
ihrem buch das ende die illusion man
sollte nicht vergessen dass das auch
kehrseiten hatten ja also überhaupt hat
erst ein mal der auch dieser wandel von
der industriellen moderne zu spät
moderne massive kia zu halten nicht ecke
die wir uns auch immer wir uns immer
mehr bewusst werden in den letzten
jahren oder auch wir werden dazu
gezwungen uns irgendwo ist zu werden
einmal ja auch auf die bastille soziale
struktur angeht da werden wir vielleicht
auch immer darauf eingehen dass ja auch
diese aufbrechen der nivellierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft eben nicht nur
gewinner sondern auch verlierer hat eben
auch eine neue unterklasse eine neue
prekäre klasse aber wir haben auch
selbst wenn man jetzt in die neue
mittelklasse selbst hineinschaut in
diese neue man könnte sagen dominante
kultur der selbstverwirklichung und der
singularität auch dort sieht man
schattenseiten oder kehrseiten
also ist auch der an ebene kann man
natürlich sagen also der lebensstil der
erfolgreichen selbstverwirklichung also
eine lebensstil der selbstentfaltung und
sozialen erfolg im grunde miteinander
in einklang bringen will also wenn er
funktioniert ist ja fantastisch
erfolgreiche selbstentfaltung ja
schreiben sie höchstens mal soll sich
selbst seien aber dabei möglichst
erfolgreich bitteschön also man könnte
sagen so eine art synthese bourgeoisie
und romantik die wir da auch in der
neuen mittelklasse erleben also einmal
als diese bürgerliche tradition dass auf
bildung und erfolg aus zu sein und
gleichzeitig die romantische tradition
auch selbstentfaltung und in idealer
weise könnte man sagen funktioniert das
dann auch insofern hat das auch eine
hohe es natürlich eine hohe befriedigung
verheißung könnte man sagen
dieser lebensstil aber was ist wenn er
nicht funktioniert und das interessante
ist ja dass wenn man genauer hinschaut
dass dieser lebensstil der erfolgreichen
selbstverwirklichung auch ein sehr hohes
enttäuschungspotenzial hat das heißt
also dass enttäuschungen also auch
negative erlebnisse
das potenzial dafür sehr hoch ist und
das hat auch systematisch gründe also
ein grund ist etwa dass man sagen kann
dass der lebensstil der
selbstverwirklichung sehr stark
erlebnisorientiert ist also erlebnis
heißt also der die all age ii gelingt
dann wenn man ihn fühlt also wenn man
dieses gelegen spürt wenn man es erlebt
das ist also es geht also nicht um einen
objektiven standard könnte man sagen für
gelingen so wie in der klassischen
industriellen moderne wenn man da einen
bestimmten lebensstandard hat ein
bestimmtes einkommen hatte so weiter
könnte man sagen also man hat es
geschafft das war objektiv sichtbar und
für einen selber auch das objektiven
kriterien aber die spätmoderne kultur
ist ja für die emotionalisierte und es
geht darum eben immer darum ob man diese
stimmigkeit spürt nicht also ist denn
dieser dieser reise wirklich gelungen
die man macht ist der beruf in dem man
lebt irland ist der beruf in dem man
arbeitet wirklich erfüllend das kann
sich ja auch verändern ist die
partnerschaft in der man lebt wirklich
erfüllt auch das kann sich ändern
das ist ja eine große fragilität könnte
man sagen wenn es also wenn das ziel
positives erleben authentizität gefühle
sind das sind eben gefühle die auch sie
verändern können vielleicht sogar in die
richtung die man zu seinem beruf oder
auch die sinn stifte und das ist
natürlich auch seine gefühle von passen
könnte man sagen und sinnhafte passung
auch das ist etwas was ich ändern kann
also dass man könnte sagen das sind sehr
viele anspruchsvolle kriterien
die man jetzt hat also kriterien nicht
des lebens stellen das unter der
lebensqualität die eben sind sie auch
noch mal verändern können wo man sich
selbst auch verändern kann und das
enthält natürlich ein
enttäuschungspotenzial das ist also
denke ich ein wichtiger punkt ein
zweiter punkt ist stichwort
enttäuschungspotenzial ist als sie
gerade die spätmoderne kultur ihr sehr
stark von vergleichen lebt von
vergleichen technologien das könnte man
sagen verglichen hat man sich immer also
schon sagt loso hatte ja auch über
soziale ungleichheit genau darüber schon
geschrieben hat sich darüber beklagt
also dem moment wenn die menschen sich
begonnen haben zu vergleichen
essberger habt dann geht's halt ab und
das ist ja eigentlich das offenbar dann
bei ihm auch also identisch mit dem
gesellschafts zustand also dem moment
wenn man sieht was er erreicht dann
vergleicht man sich und dann beginnen
die probleme
insofern kann man sagen dass es gab es
ja immer schon aber ich würde schon
sagen dass in der spätmoderne kultur da
gibt es viele indizien dass auch diese
vergleichs technologien sich einfach
auch institutionalisiert haben also im
internet zum beispiel vergleicht man die
likes man vergleicht die links war
vergleich die popularität im internet
einsetzt fotos auf instagram und sich
gleich wie viele leute sich das
anschauen also ob das jetzt interessant
scheint dieses eigene leben dass man da
postet oder weniger und vor allen dingen
man sieht dass interessante leben der
anderen vergleicht sich damit nun und
und wenn man auf die masse blick gibt es
natürlich viel mehr verlieren als
gewinnen
ist es einmal da so man könnte auch
sagen dass in der vergleichsweise häufig
und diese tendenz drinsteckt den anderen
immer also eher als als überlegen oder
interessanter wahrzunehmen als man als
selbst also gerade in so fern je mehr
man sich vergleicht umso mehr
enttäuschungen könnte man sagen aus und
her je mehr desto mehr frustration gibt
es auch als auch da haben wir könnte man
sagen so ein systematisch enttäuschung
systematisches enttäuschung fällt in der
spätmoderne und eine fixierung darauf
wie man wirkt nach außen mehr darauf aus
wie man eigentlich ist und dass ein
möchte dass er genau das ist natürlich
auch noch mal so eine art doppelte
interessante doppelstrukturen der kultur
der singularitäten weil es eigentlich
könnte man sagen der häufig darum geht
auf beiden also in beiden rechnungen
könnte man sagen erfreulich erfolgreich
zu sein also einerseits möchte man
selber diese singularität spüren möchte
selber auch dieses passus gefühl
des authentischen spüren und
gleichzeitig möchte man aber möglichst
auch anderen gegenüber singulär
erscheinen also dieser erfolg über
singularität auch da kann man wieder
sagen idealerweise passt dass beides
zusammen
aber was ist wenn nicht also kann auch
nach außen singulär erscheinen nach
innen hin fühlt sich das aber völlig
unauthentisch an dann ist man
unzufrieden oder mutiert nach innen hin
hat man das stimmungs gefühl nach außen
hin wird es aber gar nicht sichtbar auch
dann könnte man nur zufrieden werden
also auch da sieht man noch also in
dieser mann ist eine doppelstruktur dass
das spätmoderne objekts das sowohl man
könnte sagen ihnen orientiert ist als
auch außen orientiert ist also in diese
doppelstruktur lauert natürlich auch
noch mal ein erhebliches
enttäuschungspotenzial auswege aus
diesem leiden der neuen mittelschicht
also erstmal bin ich auch lange es ist
im kern betrifft das die neue
mittelschicht aber dieser diese kultur
von der wähler sprachen wirkt ja auch
der arena sie erscheint ja sehr
attraktiv die welt ja auch über die
medien zum beispiel transportiert in die
gesellschaft hinein mit dem ausweg ist
das etwas schwierig also dass das
interessante ist ja dass zum beispiel
psychologische ratgeber sich genau mit
diesen fragen mit der weile beschäftigen
also das ist ja für mich also zunehmend
interessant sich die psychologische
ratgebertexte anzuschauen weil hier
genau auf diese probleme auch reagier
reicht und da gibt es dann also es gibt
nicht wirklich auswege aber es ist zum
beispiel die sie dann die ganze frage
des emotions management spielt natürlich
eine große rolle
nicht also wie geht man mit seinen
emotionen und wie geht man auch mit
seinen negativen emotionen um sollte man
sich darauf nicht besser nicht fixieren
der viele rad kunst des scheiterns einer
hochzeit wo der neue stolz ist und so
weiter es gibt ja eine ganze reihe und
jetzt könnte man sagen die
psychologischen ratgeber die bleiben an
der oberfläche oder gehen gar nicht bis
in den kern aber ich finde sie schon
interessant weil sie natürlich sogar
street versuchen die hand zu geben wie
alltags techniken immer genau mit diesen
bedingungen umgehen kann aber ich würde
sagen diese
grundsätzliche widersprüchlichkeit oder
auch spannungsgeladen haitis
spätmodernen kultur wird dadurch
natürlich nicht überwunden ist muss man
sich aber klar machen jede moderne
kultur ist oder jede moderne lebenshaus
in die spannungsgeladene es gleich für
das klassische bürgertum genauso wie für
die angestellten existenz in der
industriellen gesellschaft und es gilt
jetzt eben auch für die spätmoderne jan
dieses paradoxe element drehen also
diese entspannungstechniken usw sie da
irgendwie auch teil einer selbst
optimierungsprogramm so könnte man das
ja auch verstehen und insofern folgen
sie derselben logik wieder einfach mit
andere ja das stimmt und ich denke auch
ein interessanter punkt ist natürlich
auch wie geht die spätmoderne kultur mit
negativen erfahrungen mit negativen
gefühlen um das scheint mir so eine krux
zu sein also die spätmoderne kultur ist
in vieler hinsicht eine eine kultur
positive emotion also das findet
erstmals zunächst einmal eine vehemente
emotionalisierung stadt also emotionen
erscheint auch legitim
das ist ja auch diese frage wie fühlt
man sich in seinem eigenen leben ist ja
ist ja eine völlig legitime frage vor 50
jahren hätte dass wir das illegitime
gewesen hätte er das immer so eine
gefälligkeit gewesen die nach außen gar
nicht vermittelbar gewesen wäre aber
heute ist das natürlich ganz zentral
insofern sind wir auch sehr stark
beeinflusst in der spätmoderne von der
von der psychologie von der positiven
psychologie die usa mit 50er 60er jahren
starten lässt mezler usw
woher auch dieser gedanke der
selbstverwirklichung zwar nicht stand
aber der damals der stadt popularisiert
wurde durch die psychologie also daher
denke ich haben wir ja auch diesen
begriff für mittlerweile und das
interessante ist aber also dass diese
positive psychologie von der wir denke
ich in unserem alltag so carola sehr
stark beeinflusst sind probleme hat mit
negativen gefühlen mit negativen
erfahrungen umzugehen sondern das sagen
dass die klassische moderne kultur oder
sogar eine religiöse kultur natürlich
eine ganz andere instrumente hatte mit
negativen erfahrungen die krankheit tod
scheitern nicht gelingen enttäuschung
und so weiter umzugehen und aber die
spätere kultur hat eigentlich wenig
instrumentarien und mit diesen negativen
erfahrungen umzugehen da er wieder in
häufig die neigung dass die dass die
negativen erfahrung wieder als chance
gesehen werden also zum beispiel
krankheit als chance oder scheitern
ausscheider krise als chance wieder auf
die korona krise dazu also immer hat
dieser versucht das eigentlich
umzudrehen eine positive richtung und
damit wird man der negativität
möglicherweise nicht gerecht ja ich
möchte mit ihnen ins im zweiten teil
noch ein bisschen auf die
gesellschaftlichen schattenseiten auf
die politischen implikationen schauen
insbesondere dieser trennung zwischen
einer neuen mittelschicht über die wir
gesprochen haben und diese outen mit
lustig vielleicht können sie die noch
ein bisschen besser beschreiben weil da
erklären sie ja auch so populistische
fällen aus dieser alten mittelschicht
genau also wenn man sich jetzt die
sozialstruktur der späten moderne
gesellschaft anschaut dann haben wir da
wir sind ja schon kurz darüber
eingegangen
man könnte sagen eigentlich ein
aufbrechen die simulierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft auf der einen
seite eben der aufstieg der neuen
mittelklasse der neuen akademikerinnen
und akademiker auf der anderen seite
auch der abstieg an einen neuen
unterklasse oder prekären klasse also
personen die er in der besten service
class nennen die in den so genannten
einfachen dienstleistungen beschäftigt
sind
auch das ist ja ein segment das in der
spätmoderne gewachsen ist also wieder
erleben wir nicht nur einen wachstum in
der wissensökonomie sie dann auch ein
wachstum in den monaten einfachen
dienstleistungen das ist auch die
kehrseite der industrialisierung also
die spätmoderne gesellschaft ist in
vieler hinsicht ebenfalls im westen eine
ent industrialisierte gesellschaft also
die der industrielle bereich hat ja
immer weniger anteil an der
erwerbstätigkeit oder teilweise nur noch
zehn prozent oder höchstens 20 prozent
früher weil es über 50 prozent
aber wo bleiben die person manchen
rutschen eben ab in die service cloud
also in die heimat in das für neue jobs
entstanden das sind also jobs zum
beispiel ob das jetzt im bereich
reinigung oder im bereich transport oder
im bereich sicherheit sind also das sind
eben die sogenannten
niedrigqualifizierten was ja auch schon
ein respektierter begriff ist also
personen das sind doch überall durch
stellt für den migrantinnen und
migranten
es gibt ja auch der eine gruppe auch
durch eine globale oder transnationale
prozesse also service klar ist die also
auch die grenzen überschreitet also hat
sogenannten haushaltsnahen
dienstleistungen pflegeberufe teilweise
und so weiter da gibt es ja auch einen
großen bedarf könnte man sagen der späte
und gerne an diesen einfachen
dienstleistungen
also das ist auf jeden fall auch eine
neue gruppe eine neue klasse in manchen
ländern ist sie etwas kleiner in manchem
etwas größer und dann gibt es aber dann
in der mitte und darauf wollte er gerade
hinaus natürlich auch noch die
traditionelle mittelklasse das ist
könnte man sagen dass er aber der
nivellierten mittelstandsgesellschaft
also das ist eigentlich eine gruppe die
wenn man sich das historisch anschaut
also in der regulierten
mittelstandsgesellschaft mal im zentrum
der gesellschaft stand und jetzt aber
selber man könnte sagen immer mehr in
einer sandwich position gerät die neue
mittelklasse mit der polregionen
akademiker steigt auf die neue
unterklasse steigt ab mit der mitte eben
jetzt die traditionelle mittelklasse das
eben sind eben personen die mittlere
bildungsabschlüsse haben die also
klassische tätigkeiten das ist kleine
angestellte facharbeiter weil doch
selbstständige haben die häufig auch er
in im ländlichen oder kleinen
städtischen bereich leben also ebenfalls
überdurchschnittlich die mittlere
bildungsabschlüsse haben und das ist das
war eine industriellen gesellschaft die
mit lustigen moderne die mitte der
gesellschaft könnte man sagen und das
ist gilt jetzt aber in der spätere der
also nicht und sie sagen die sie nicht
nur von einem wirtschaftlichen abstieg
gegen die bedroht oder eben den mit
sondern auch von einer von einer
entwertung oder einem abwertungen
eigentlich das ist ganz schön heiß ich
meine inwiefern da ein ökonomischer
abstieg droht das ist sicher auch noch
mal je nach nation sehr unterschiedliche
teilweise hält sich ja die traditionelle
mittel jetzt auch noch ganz gut
ökonomisch also ist noch nicht unbedingt
abgestiegen also in westdeutschland ist
das zum beispiel teilweise der fall ich
denke auch in der schweiz in anderen
ländern zb den usa ist die
traditionellen mittel das ist viel
stärker auch ökonomisch unter druck
aber was ich jetzt vor einigen
hervorheben möchte ist eben dieser diese
prozesse der mann konnte seinen
kulturellen deklassierung oder
kulturellen entwerter oder symbolischen
entwertung wenn man so will in der
traditionellen mittelklasse also selbst
wenn es ihnen teilweise auf materielle
recht gut geht erleben sie doch wie auch
durch ein zeithorizont man könnte sagen
ihre sie ihr status sich verringert ich
denke an ein element das ganz wichtig
ist natürlich der fakt für bildung nicht
also die mittlere bildungsabschlüsse
waren mal
eben das normale oder eigentlich in den
50er 60er 70er jahren damit einen
mittleren bildungsabschluss mitten in
der gesellschaft aber im zuge der
akademisierung bedeutet natürlich
mittlere bildungsabschlüsse als nicht
die universität besucht zu haben ja
jetzt eine relativ einen abstieg also
man ist nicht wer man ist im grunde
gleich geblieben ja und steigt aber
darüber steigt aber ab weil andere
einsaßen überholt ich denke gerade
dieser faktor bildung ist ganz zentral
und das geht und das wirkt sich dann
natürlich auch länger als im beruflichen
bereich auch aus dass eben bestimmte
berufe die auch klassischer weise also
man konnte sein gesellschaftliches
normalmaß als angestellte oder
facharbeiter ausgemacht haben dass sie
eben jetzt angesichts der akademisierung
und der neue mittelklasse nicht mehr das
normalmaß darstellen auch da das
eigentlich die eigenen leistungen sind
gewissermaßen gleich geblieben aber der
status ist es relativ zu den anderen
gesunken oder ein drittes element ist
auch ganz wichtig ist irgendwie stadland
differenz also weil traditionelle mittel
tatsächlich überdurchschnittlich nicht
in den metropolregionen sondern im
kleinstädtischen ländlichen bereichen
geben und die sind in vielen ländern
denken wir etwa an die usa oder in
frankreich oder auch ostdeutschland sind
gerade diese ländlichen regionen werden
immer mehr zur abgehängten region das
heißt also es gibt ja auch ein brain
drain in die großen städte
es gibt ja auch ein verlust der
infrastruktur das heißt also wenn man in
diesem diesen gegenden lebt die eben
auch in der industriellen moderne konnte
man sich auch war in der mitte der
gesellschaft leben wenn man in diesem
kleinen ort gelebt hat das erscheint
jetzt aber nicht mehr man sieht immer
den vergleich zu den metropolen man
sieht also auch die die prozesse das
wegziehen es aus den kleinen orten man
sieht und verlust der der infrastruktur
sieht auch teilweise ökonomische
verluste
also insofern ergibt sich deutlich auf
verschiedenen ebenen bildung beruf
stadland ergeben sich hinters kanal
menschen die populistische parteien
wählen oder die mit den viele schon auf
die straße gehen teilweise also ich
meine das ist natürlich jetzt keine das
ist natürlich nicht so dass alle in der
traditionellen messe populistische
parteien wäre ja sondern viele sind auch
weiterhin eigentlich in dem
appellierten parteienspektrum enthalten
also bei den konservativen auch bei den
sozialdemokraten
aber es gibt natürlich gerade innerhalb
der tradition in anderer weise auch
innerhalb der unterklasse natürlich
eifrig er ein klasse schon tendenzen
also wie sich dann oder diese frage wie
sich dieser statusverlust und
anerkennung aus verlust der tat auch ein
fall gefühlte anerkennungs verlust ist
wieder sich politisch umgesetzt und dann
setzen dass ich teilweise eben um in
richtung populismus und rechnung
rechtspopulismus also auch in eine
bestimmte form von eliten kritik also
diese kritik an den urbanen eliten die
dort ja gerne transportiert wird oder
auch zb die globalisierungskritik die ja
sehr stark von von rechtspopulismus
vertreten wird auch der findet dann
teilweise fruchtbaren boden weil man
dann die globalisierung eigentlich auch
als antriebsfaktor hinter diesen
ökonomischen prozessen bittet die wir
uns gerade das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt die globalisierung wie man dazu
steht dass ich sie sagen nach links
rechts und so weiter ist nicht mehr die
entscheidende unterscheidung politisch
sondern ob man irgendwie populistisch
ist oder kosmopolitisch zum beispiel
dass sie haben auch andere begriffe
kultur essentielles oder hyper wir genau
das ist ja etwas also das lehne ich mich
an also eine politikwissenschaftliche
analysen an die er in den letzten jahren
erschienen sind also nehme ich diese
frage wie hat sich die zentrale
konfliktlinie eigentlich in der
gesellschaft verändert dass sie die
politik wissenschaft entsprechen der
gerne von klimaschutz also
konfliktlinien also immer könnt ihr dann
die politische landschaft das
klassischerweise durch ein oder mehrere
konfliktlinie strukturiert und so denkt
man dann auch so probieren sich auch die
parteien und die wähler und so weiter
und die klassische politische konflikte
in der industriellen moderne war
natürlich die links/rechts
unterscheidung gewissermaßen arbeit
versus kapital nicht also dann auch
sozialdemokratische versus konservative
parteien und das hat ja auch das denken
sehr lange strukturiert das ist
natürlich auch weiterhin nicht
verschwunden also es gibt weiterhin auch
diese differenz sie hat auch weiterhin
bedeutung
aber es hat sich im grunde jedenfalls
zeigen dass die analysen einiger
politikwissenschaftler in den letzten
jahrzehnten vor allem seit den 90er
jahren sich eigentlich eine neue
konfliktlinie ausgewählte dachte er sich
auch die wähler dann kopieren und die
werte und interessen der wähler
gruppieren und das ist eben diese
unterscheidung zwischen das ist
teilweise etwas unglücklich formuliert
kosmopoliten werdens kommentare das ist
ja ein begriff der immer verwendet wird
also auf der einen seite und konnte auch
seinen globalisierungs befürworter wäre
das globalisierungskritiker oder
personen die also sehr stark auch wer
entgrenzung globale entgrenzung setzen
auf liberale werte setzen auf der einen
seite das kann stärker linksliberale sei
es kann doch stärker wirtschaftsliberal
sein und auf der anderen seite haben wir
aber personen die gerade da sehr
skeptisch sind gegenüber der
globalisierung auch zum beispiel auch
eher nationale regulierungen fördern die
zum beispiel auch stärker eine nationale
kultur betonen nationale ökonomie und
das eigentlich könnte man sagen dass im
2 das sind die beiden neuen lager die
sich gegenüberstehen und die das sieht
man ja sehr schnell also nicht woody
links rechts unterscheide und diese lage
eigentlich durch schneider das ganze ist
eigentlich diagonal zur links rechts
unterscheidung weil auch in dem
kommunistischen also globalisierung
skeptischen lager gibt es ja auch er
konnte mal ihre rechte und ihre danke
untergruppen aber insofern sieht man
dass dieser diese neue konfliktlinie
eben nicht einfach nur eine verlängerung
der alten links rechts unterscheidung
ist oder dass seine neue unterscheidung
1 gekommen ist und jetzt kann man das
eben übersetzen
auch in die sozialstruktur die
sozialstruktur modell das wir vorher
hatten die man sagen kann also der
sogenannte kosmopolitismus oder die
sogenannten kosmopoliten und die
globalisierungs befürworter sind eben
primär in der neuen mittelklasse
beheimatet also in der metropolregion
und das sind sie sind auch der träger
des konnte sagen dynamisierung des
liberalismus der letzten jahrzehnte
kriminalisierung des liberalismus heißt
das ist etwas realismus der bank heute
sagen auf entgrenzung auf deregulierung
auf gesellschaftliche dynamik gesetzt
hat und zwar sowohl in einem eher
neoliberalen so wirtschaftsliberalen
zweig seit den 80er 90er jahren als auch
in der linksliberalen 2 wo es eben darum
geht zum beispiel auch die
persönlichkeitsrechte von individuen zu
stärken gegenüber der gesellschaft also
auch da mehr dynamik könnte man sagen
hineinzubringen
und das ist also ein könnte sein dass
politisch also dieser dynamisierung des
liberalismus und wenn man sagen die
politische übersetzung dieses
kosmopolitischen lagers also auch ins
parteienspektrum hinein und da ist
natürlich die frage was ist jetzt der
gegenpol oder gegenpol der des
kommunistischen lagers wo eben auch
unter gruppen aus der traditionell
mittelklasse eine große rolle spielen
oder teilweise aus der prekären klasse
ist der gegenpol ist jetzt also
jedenfalls wenn man das hier zugespitzt
senkt im rechtspopulismus eigentlich
mittlerweile auszumachen der ja sehr
stark auf regulierung setzt der sehr
stark auf nationale schließung selbst
und zwar sowohl wiederum ökonomischen
wie auch im kulturellen was man ja beide
ist eigentlich auch zusammen denken ja
genau zusammen denken ist das stichwort
weil sie liefern ja aus soziologie ganz
wenige
also empfehlungen sonst sie beschreiben
sie analysieren
aber es gibt trotzdem immer wieder so
stellen begriffe die vorkommen zb sagen
sie dieses der liberalisierung damit
sind wir zu weit gefahren da ist an ein
ende gekommen und sie fordern einen
einbetten den liberalismus
also irgendwie mehr regulierung aber
auch nicht zu viel vielleicht können sie
müssen erläutert er was sie sich da
vorstellen wie das ist zunächst mal muss
man ja sagen dass es geht ja tatsächlich
darum aufzuzeigen
das haben wir ja ist auch gerade
versucht also wie in der spätmoderne
gesellschaft eben eine bestimmte soziale
struktur mit einer bestimmten kultur
nach einer bestimmten politik letztlich
zusammenhängt und jetzt kann man aber
sagen dass ich würde seinen letzten zehn
jahren und spätestens seit der
finanzkrise auch immer mir als die
strukturellen spannungen innerhalb der
spätmoderne gesellschaft deutlich
geworden sind und daher ungleich die
zugenommen hat also eine wäre er eine
spannung wir eben sozial die verstärkung
der sozialen ungleichheit also im stream
zwischen superreichen und prekären aber
zum beispiel auch die vernachlässigung
öffentlicher infrastruktur oder auch
gewisse momente man sollte sagen
kultureller des integration also wenn
man etwa an die enthemmte kommunikation
im internet denkt also auch da haben wir
immer mehr
man könnte sagen
phänomene die sich also wo man sieht
dass im grunde die dynamisierung der
spätmoderne man könnte vielleicht sagen
in einer art über dynamisierung gemündet
sind und so dass wir ja jetzt schon seit
einigen jahren im politischen bereich
und zwar nicht nur im kommunistischen
lager selbstkritische diskurse haben
also wie soll es jetzt weitergehen also
dieser also die dieser eindruck dass man
nicht einfach die sind die firma xerox
liberalismus verlängern kann und ihn
eben unendlich jemals weiterführt ich
denke das hat sich doch letzten jahren
in vielen lagern
sowohl links als auch bei konservativen
verbreitet und daher knüpfe ich jetzt
genau an
also es geht mir jetzt auch nicht darum
bislang war es nicht einfach einen einen
mitten in die brust so aus dem ärmel zu
schütteln und gesagt einfach wie so ein
fantasiegebilde sie finden schon man
muss etwas tun gegen die zunehmende
polarisierung auf ganz unterschiedlichen
genau und ich denke es gibt ja schon
auch anzeichen für diesen einbetten die
wahl ist also was ich eben meine ist
also erstmals wir natürlich auch möglich
dass der rechtspopulismus sich
durchsetzt dass das gewissermaßen das
paradigma der zukunft ist das nicht
völlig ausgeschlossen
aber wenn man jetzt denkt dass auch in
der vergangenheit ist ja schon so weit
dass man könnte sagen auch aus dem also
aus dem breiten mitte links mitte rechts
spektrum ja serie war auch
paradigmenwechsel entstanden sind in der
politik das war ja in der 70er 80er
jahren auch schon so dann könnte das ja
sein dass das jetzt auch wieder der fall
ist und jetzt aber wenn man das alles
zusammennimmt könnte man sagen also die
die neue der neue imperativ oder der das
neue neue anforderungen die politik ist
ja jetzt gerade nicht mehr noch mehr zu
dynamisieren und dann im grunde mehr zu
regulieren könnte man sagen das heißt
also mehr auch diese ungleichheiten die
des integration usw ihnen bestimmte
bestimmte regeln zu unterwerfen um auf
diese art und weise zumindest bestimmte
folgen des destabilisierung des
liberalismus abzumildern hat wie zum
beispiel wir hatten ja aber die stadt
land differenz gesprochen ist natürlich
ein sehr komplex ist ein kompliziertes
thema aber man kann natürlich nicht das
land jetzt langfristig als abgehängt
betrachten oder einfach sich damit
stillschweigend abfinden sondern ein
bisschen eben wege gefunden werden um
zumindest also um stärken ihre stärkere
balance zwischen der prosperität der
metropolregion und der entwicklung der
ländlichen regionen hinzubekommen aber
es geht diese aufwertung muss irgendwie
beide seien ökonomisch und symbolen
statt den abgehängten und abgewehrt also
das wäre eben das ziel und das ist
natürlich nicht weil das ökonomisch ist
es ein ist es möglicherweise einfach
durch so einfach durchzusetzen als
kulturell und man kann natürlich
versuchen zum beispiel infrastruktur zu
stärken
auch im ländlichen bereich das ist
sicher auch ein wichtiger punkt als in
deutschland haben wir auch diese
diskussion also wie man den ländlichen
bereich stärken kann wie man da
infrastruktur halten kann also gesund
und gesundheits bereich sowie verkehrs
bringen das ist die eine seite aber auf
der anderen seite geht es darüber
sprachen wir ja auch immer um
symbolische anerkennung und da haben wir
ja in der spätmoderne eine enorm
auseinander entwicklung verschiedener
lebenswelten in der gesellschaft wie man
das zum beispiel auch angehen kann also
wie man da wieder eine stärkere
symbolische aufwertung der bisher
abgewehrt haben kann das ist nicht so
ganz einfach zu sehen also ein
interessantes beispiel fand sich dann
doch in der korona krise habe mich mit
den sogenannten systemrelevanten beruhen
also da haben wir ja genau dieses
segment der einfachen dienstleistungen
das ja gesellschaftlich hoch notwendig
ist das aber eigentlich in der
symbolischen anerkennung ganz unten im
grunde in der soziallehre meine hatte
man das gefühl die leute gingen auf die
baukosten haben geklatscht führen sodass
das auflegen aber wird wenn man jetzt
andere kriterien anlagen der mich nicht
ob sind diese berufe attraktiv sind sie
gesellschaftlich notwendig dann sieht
man auf einmal dass sie eigentlich einer
hohen anerkennung dass ihr hohe
anerkennung verdienen die frage ist
natürlich wie das jetzt in normalzeiten
wenn die korona krise vorbei ist
überhaupt umgesetzt werden kann
aber insofern ist es ein interessanter
weil man da natürlich auch sieht es geht
hier auch sicherlich auch materielle
entlohnung es geht aber auch um
symbolische anerkennung aber es ist
sicherlich sehr schwierig und er sehe
ich auch keinen ausweg wie diese diese
symbolischen differenzen in der
gesellschaft wie die gewissermaßen neu
austariert werden kann ich meine so eine
krise zeigt auch immer wie anfällig eine
ganze kultur eine ganze gesellschaft
sein kann
vielleicht macht sie uns auch bewusst
dass wir eher auf resilienz uns
fokussieren sollten als auch noch mehr
wachstum und was wie könnte das haus
leer also das würde ich auch sagen dass
das in der krise in der kohlekrise sehr
deutlich geworden ist und als wäre ja
auch
herausforderung für eine neue politik
und man sich jetzt ein bett in der
liberalismus nennen will oder wie auch
immer
indem ich eine sehr viel stärker risiko
politisch orientierte politik und
risikopolitik dass das heißt ja das ist
also eine politik die versucht irgendwie
besann meist bestimmte negative zustände
zu vermeiden also der der gesellschaft
mehrere williams also mehr
widerstandsfähigkeit eigentlich zu
ermöglichen indem man präventiv agiert
also man sieht das jetzt ja im
gesundheitswesen also wie viel man
sicherlich auch zukünftig für solche
pandemien er gewappnet sein sollte man
sollte vielleicht auch für digitale
crash zu gewappnet sein
oder man sollte auch vielleicht für
natürlich auch für den klimawandel
gewappnet sein das ist ja alles
verschiedene phänomene wo man sagen kann
es geht ja eigentlich und präventive
politik es geht um risikopolitik aber
was man sagen muss ist natürlich dass
diese risikopolitik wenn sie wichtiger
wird und es gibt ja einige anzeichen
dass ihr wichtiger wird dass das im
vergleich zu dem was wir in der moderne
sonst an politik gewöhnt sind natürlich
eine eine politik reduzierte ansprüche
ist weil die moderne politik der
klassischerweise positive maßstäbe
positive zielvorstellung fortschritts
vorstellung wohlstand für alle autonomie
für alle
das waren ja die ziele sowohl der
industriellen moderne aber auch dass
genannten die arisierung ausgeben ist
was sie hatten ja eigentlich sicher hier
könnte man sagen fortschritts ziele die
teilweise auch umgesetzt wurden
teilweise nicht aber jetzt auch man sich
darauf konzentrieren die katastrophe zu
vermeiden
nur dass hier eine politik des negativen
das ist die frage ob das ausreicht aber
das scheint einen jeweils eine
notwendigkeit so sein dass man zumindest
auch in der politik des negativen
betreibt aber die ganz generell das ist
schon meine vermutung ist dass also hier
jetzt endlich in eine phase eintreten in
der auch der klassischen moderne
fortschritts maßstab immer fragiler wird
immer zerbrechlicher wird auch immer
weniger realistisch erscheint also wir
haben ja schon seit den 70er jahren
steht weil könnten das wachstum haben
wir einen kritischen diskurs die aber
interessanterweise ein thema also am
randen doch mitgelaufen ist letzten
jahrzehnten keine große rolle spielt
aber jetzt denke ich in der fortschritts
gedanklich seinem wesenskern der moderne
er steht jetzt muss man so muss man erst
mal sehr deutlich betonen dass der ist
der fortschritt genannte wirklich für
die moderne seite her aufklärung also
nicht ganz konstitutiv ist also ohne
fortschritt gedanke gibt es eigentlich
kein modernes projekt der moderne wie
haben was das mal genannt lebt eben vom
fortschritt gedacht jetzt kann man
natürlich fragen wie wird der ausbruch
stets ihrem wohlstand geht es eher um
die mündigkeit und emanzipation aber
dass es um fortschritt geht das hat
natürlich könnte man sagen die moderne
politik und das moderne
gesellschaftsverständnis angetrieben
und wenn sie jetzt davon verabschieden
also ich denke es gibt gewisse anzeichen
das kann natürlich auch sagen dass das
nur eine vorübergehende delle ist und
dann geht s dann doch bis jetzt mal so
im 2 also 20er jahren auch schon eine
solche delle gab also sehr stark auch
entwicklung von dystopien auch jetzt
erleben wir ja wenn wir zum beispiel als
die populärkultur anschauen also ein
erstaunliches florieren von disco pia
also gerade von negativen
zukunftsszenarien also es gibt auch
ganzjährige wo es darum geht also das
ist schon mal bemerkenswert also es kann
schon sein dass dieser klassische
fortschritts im maßstab eigentlich dass
man den nicht mehr einfach verlängern
kann also auch gerade klimawandel ist
natürlich ist ein wichtiges stichwort
dass man sieht also einfach ein weiter
so ist eigentlich nicht möglich es geht
eher darum auch mit bestimmten verlusten
zu rechnen
und dass diese verluste also dass man
sich mit den verlusten auch arrangiert
aber da sind wir wieder bei den fotos
wir frieden hatten den wir vorher hatten
die negativen gefühle und die nägel die
negativität hat gerade die spenden oder
eine kultur eigentlich ein problem mit
diesen umzug ist ja interessant eine
letzte frage vielleicht auch sie haben
ich habe gelesen sie schreiben ein neues
buch oder sind ganz am anfang aber es
geht um verlust um verlust erfahrung ist
es genau das was sie daran interessiert
genau also ich dass diese feier nach
verlusten über lust erfahrung hat sich
jetzt eigentlich ergeben auch aus dem
letzten buch weil ich da ja auch sicher
dass schon angesprochen angesprochen
habe diese dieses verhältnis von
fortschritt und verlusten der
spätmoderne und weiß ich eigentlich an
diesem thema verlust und verlust
erfahrung ebenso interessant und wichtig
finde das einmal anders ein sehr
aktuelles thema also wir haben das ja
angesprochen auch angesichts des
klimawandels oder auch angesichts
neben der deindustrialisierung könnte
man sagen
erleben wir mehr verlust erfahrungen
jemals in den westlichen gesellschaften
aber gleichzeitig ist es natürlich ein
ganz klassisches thema der moderne von
anfang an wir hatten ja von den usa
angesprochen
für den weiter die moderne auch schon
eine einzige verlust erfahren fremden
sofa ist das eigentlich ein sehr
klassisches die immer die moderne hat
immer von anfang an auch verluste
thematisiert und das finde ich so
reizvoll also man kann jetzt über die
moderne insgesamt noch mal rehkitz wir
sind leider schon am ende dieses
gesprächs ich danke ihnen sehr für
dieses ganz besondere einzigartige
gespräch wie ein dankeschön ja nächste
woche dreht sich hier alles um tiere
barbara bleisch spricht mit dem
philosophen bernd ladwig über
massentierhaltung und die frage ob es
eigentlich moralisch okay ist wenn wir
tiere essen oder sie als haustiere
halten
und jetzt gleich erwartet sie eine
musikalische grenzerfahrung anlässlich
des lucerne festivals zeigen wie einen
film über das vielleicht schwierigste
klavierkonzert der musikgeschichte die
krank tochter des schweizer musikers und
komponisten dieter ammer
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]